bonjour claude bonjour heureuse de vous
retrouver dans la matinale d'ayrté
france alors on en parlait déjà la
semaine dernière avec cette coalition
anti netanyahu qui est maintenant à la
tête de la knesset quelles sont les
priorités de ce nouveau gouvernement
claude y est d'ailleurs que vous l'avez
dit à l'instant l'épreuve de vérité
d'aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya cette marche
des drapeaux qui fait que les
nationalistes religieux israéliens
veulent défiler dans jérusalem-est pour
célébrer la réunification de jérusalem
alors cette marche avait été reporté par
deux fois par le gouvernement précédent
parce qu'il y avait des différends sur
le trajet aujourd'hui elle est autorisée
et effectivement elle présente des
risques en plus bien entendu des
palestiniens et le hamas ont averti que
si elle s'aventurait sur l'esplanade des
mosquées s'il y avait des comportements
agressifs
il y aurait forcément des répliques si
donc un défi très important pour le
gouvernement israélien est ce que
monsieur naftali bennet puisque c'est un
nationaliste puisque il est d'un
gouvernement de droite et qu'il a donc
l'oreille des éléments les plus radicaux
peut contenir cette manifestation pour
qu'elles débordent pas et qu'il n'y ait
pas de provocation vis-à-vis des
palestiniens c'est très difficile parce
que aller à jérusalem est
pour ces manifestants c'est déjà une
provocation naturellement d'un autre
côté le hamas peut être tenté de donner
sa chance à ce nouveau gouvernement
plutôt que de provoquer une crise
politique en israël
dès aujourd'hui il sait par ailleurs que
l'appareil militaire n'a pas changé que
le miz de défense et le même monsieur
bening ans est le seul ministre de 2,7
de monsieur netanyahou qui soit rester
en fonction et cet ancien chef d'état
major des armées est toujours ministre
de la défense par conséquent le hamas
sait parfaitement à quoi s'en tenir
au cas où il y aurait des tentations de
tirer des roquettes sur sur israël moi
je fais plutôt le pari que ça sera très
difficile mais que cette journée
finalement se passera bien de façon à ce
que le gouvernement puisse remplir sa
tâche et sa tâche est d'abord de
fabriquer un budget parce que on ne dit
pas très souvent mais israël vit sans
budget depuis deux ans il ya des budgets
provisoires qui ont été votée par la
knesset
mais le gouvernement de monsieur
netanyahou était tombé en décembre
dernier parce qu'il était incapable de
faire voter le budget et donc il faut
que le gouvernement nouveau installé
hier face un budget et puisque c'est un
gouvernement de coalition il a peut-être
plus de capacités qu'un autre de
fabriquer un budget qui passera à la
knesset
le ministre du budget c'est monsieur
avigdor lieberman et c'est à lui que
revient cette responsabilité pour
couvrir l'année 2020 donc l'année déjà
écoulé et puis l'année dans laquelle
nous sommes 2021
ensuite il s'attaquera au budget de
l'année prochaine 2022
le gouvernement israélien à environ
trois mois pour faire ce cet exploit de
faire voter un budget exploit sur lequel
monsieur netanyahou a trébuché
par conséquent c'est un véritable défi
et il y à un relatif consensus dans
cette dans ce gouvernement de coalition
8 go conduite partie très différents les
uns les autres
mais il ya un consensus pour après deux
ans de crise politique
son jet et sur fond de crise pandémique
pour d'abord avoir un budget de relance
de l'économie
c'est ça qui est important pour endiguer
le chômage
en israël pour probablement dotée la
santé d'un budget renforcer et pour
également financer de nouvelles
infrastructures en israël et chaque
composante de ce gouvernement fera
valoir ses intérêts qui seront prises en
compte dans ce budget se forme
naturellement de dépenses nouvelles
donc c'est ça les priorités de ceux de
ce nouveau gouvernement claude il nous
reste une minute on a entendu benyamin
nétanyahou qui a juré je cite de
renverser le gouvernement à la première
occasion cette coalition de huit partis
très large est ce qu'elle est est ce
qu'elle est viable
c'est très difficile et bien sûr il est
raisonnable pour les observateurs
politiques de dire que sa durée sera
probablement courte
je n'en suis pas si certain beaucoup de
d'acteurs de la vie politique et aussi
de la vie économique en israël ne
veulent pas que monsieur dernier où
reviennent au pouvoir dans les mois qui
viennent et par conséquent veulent
donner sa chance à ce nouveau
gouvernement qui sur le plan économique
sera probablement assez dynamique pour
forger un budget delà de la relance
économique et pour trouver une forme de
consensus économique et social alors
évidemment ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile sur les sujets qui fâchent
c'est à dire sur les négociations avec
les palestiniens
et là il ya plutôt forte à parier il n'y
aura pas beaucoup d'évolution par
rapport au gouvernement précédent
l'egypte et la jordanie s'estimant
charge delà du maintien du cessez le feu
si c'est important c'est le président si
si qui est responsable de delà de la
négociation de ce cessez le feu
il faut évidemment le prolonger le
consolider et puis dans le fond nous
sortons d'une période dans laquelle le
président trump
avait fait une alliance très forte avec
monsieur netanyahou les acquis pour
israël de cette période vont subsister
c'est à dire que ce qui résulte de
l'accord de bethléem à savoir la
normalisation des relations entre des
émirats arabes unis israël entre le
bahreïn et d'israël va bien entendu
subsister il en est de même pour
d'autres normalisation des rats des
relations comme par exemple avec le
maroc
donc il n'y aura pas de grand changement
une inflexion sans doute et notamment le
fait que monsieur la pie xii affaires
étrangères et le gouvernement doit par
priorité rétablir des relations de
confiance avec le parti démocrate
américain et il semble que joe biden
soit disposé à faire crédit à ce nouveau
gouvernement
merci beaucoup claude pour toutes ces
explications c'est l édito diplo de la
matinale d'ayrté france